in devastating news today nintendo
president satoru iwata has passed away
at the age of 55 the news came by way of
an official Nintendo press release that
included the notification of death and
personnel change of a representative
director the statement reads quote
Nintendo deeply regrets to announce that
president Satoru Iwata passed away on
July 11 2015 jutsu a bile duct growth
awanta had been struggling with his
health for some time and skipped III
last year due to medical reasons it was
later revealed that he was undergoing
surgery for a tumor in the bile duct
which took place in June of last year a
while to join Nintendo in the 1980s as a
programmer working on games like
earthbound and the Kirby series he
eventually succeeded hiroshi yamauchi to
become the fourth president and CEO of
Nintendo Eternia which lasted 13 years
in addition he also acted as CEO of
Nintendo America for two years a
well-loved industry figure a water made
a number of positive changes throughout
his time heading up the company and led
Nintendo through the Gamecube DF we the
radius and wii u eras a lotta was named
one of Barron's magazine's top CEOs
largely due to the success of the way a
water will be sorely missed within the
gaming world and among his many fans our
thoughts go out to his family and
friends
you